it sounds like an urban legend but actor
Jim Caviezel was legitimately struck by
lightning on the set of The Passion of
the Christ and that's just one of the
setbacks he had to face during filming
Jim Caviezel is lighting up Hollywood
with his leading role as Tim Ballard in
sound of Freedom fans of the movie who
haven't kept up with the actor's career
may not remember that cavizel got lit up
himself for shooting a different movie
nearly 20 years ago and luckily survived
to tell the tale interactive Mel
Gibson's controversial but highly
successful 2004 film The Passion of the
Christ caviesel took on arguably his
biggest role as Jesus during filming the
actor's experience was fraught with
Peril including quite literally being
struck by lightning in 2003 when into
the production of The Passion of the
Christ Entertainment Weekly reported on
the lightning strike that occurred while
filming a scene cavizo wasn't the only
one hit either assistant director
yamikalini was also struck by the bolt
marking the second time that he had been
hit by lightning while working on the
movie producer Steve macaviti told
Outlet I'm about 100 feet away from them
when I glance over and see the lightning
coming out of caviesel's ears both
caviesel and mikolini got struck the
main balls had caviesel and one of its
Forks hit mikolini's umbrella when I was
hit everybody fell on their face the
ground shook that was the last shot of
the movie both caviesel and mikolini
survived the lightning strike and later
reports claim they were unharmed by the
incident but that's not the complete
truth in an interview with Peggy Noonan
of the words group cavizel described
that the experience felt like he said
about four seconds before it happened it
was quiet and then it was like someone
slapped my ears I had seven or eight
seconds of like a pink fuzzy color and
people started screaming they said I had
fire on the left side of my head and
light around my body all I can tell you
is that looked like I went to Don King's
hairstyle list between the lightning and
numerous other injuries sustained during
the production the actor ended up in the
operating room twice for serious medical
procedures he told Catholic Korea it
nearly killed me not many people get
struck by lightning I did five and a
half months of cold I had to have two
heart surgeries including open heart
surgery because of that film the
lightning strike is just one item in the
laundry list of injuries caviesel ended
up with throughout the production of The
Passion of the Christ in one instance he
sustained a deep gash in his back as a
result of an accident in a scene where
Jesus is being whipped cavizel told
today that another actor Miser board
protecting him and accidentally struck
his back with their whip confused or
record but turned around and looked at
the guy and I tell you I may be playing
Jesus but I felt like Satan at that
moment I turned to him a couple of
expertips came out of my mouth he would
later get struck in the back again which
left him with a 14-inch gash that would
eventually turn into a lasting scar
caviesel also dislocated his shoulder
while carrying a large cross and caught
pneumonia because of filming in frigid
temperatures for extended periods of
time despite all of the ways a movie
damaged the actor's body caviza
maintains that he doesn't regret working
on the project he told Catholic Korea if
we had shot that film in a studio you
wouldn't have seen that performance was
it worth it absolutely
foreign
[Music]